c'est une scène devenue habituelle pour
le festival de bd de buc la files
d'attentes pour obtenir un souvenir de
la cinquantaine de professionnels du 9e
art présent ce jour là il est bien
évident que rencontrer le public c'est
toujours un grand plaisir
je fais ce que je peux pour être
disponible pour être efficace parce que
on me demande de dessiner de dessiner de
faire des dédicaces qui soit
personnalisé et
c'est vrai que ça demande des fois un
petit peu de temps à exécuter je vois
les gens qui sont vraiment patients qui
arrivent à attendre des fois une
demi-heure attendre une heure le temps
que je termine mon dessin la plupart des
légendes bande dessinée soit picsou soit
donald de son ami qui soit celle ça
c'est les trois personnages comme
demande de dessiner le plus souvent
après ça peut arriver qu'au moment des
personnages qui sont un peu plus
secondaires on va dire comme dingo
plutôt au mini ou les filles dont pas
mal de mini les enfants pour eux c'est
de la magie en fait quand il ya un
personnage qui ce qui qui ce qui se crée
dans les mains d'un dessinateur pour eux
c'est comme c'est pas un dessinateur
c'est un magicien brad a deux lignes de
front jean torton jean-michel arroyo de
buck danny des auteurs pour adultes des
auteurs pour la jeunesse il y en a
chaque année pour tous les goûts des
artistes pour toutes les générations
c'est de rencontrer les auteurs et puis
d'avoir des belle dédicace de certains
auteurs qu'on aime bien il y en a
certains particulièrement je dirais
qu'ils sont cons trouve belle et puis
que les idées ou les histoires sont
sympas voilà l'une des auteurs préférés
de ma fille était là cette année
nora moretti donc il fallait absolument
venir donc on était là dès 10 heures ce
matin avec mes filles pour les enfants
c'est magique voir dessiner l'auteur sur
le livre le livre il a une énorme valeur
après pour cette 23e édition le festival
a accueilli plus de 7500 personnes c'est
1000 de plus que l'année précédente